what a cozy cast
dude i'm so cozy right now
these things just feel amazing jake's
head should be on but yeah
it's okay
well we got the two marshmallows the
wicked witch of the west
i did just get a haircut and uh you know
the problem was that
they're playing smash they're playing
smash up there aren't they um
just last week they yelled at us for
playing chess remember that just yelled
at us for playing smash
daniel's for playing championships
and i quote this is objectively worse
right well daniel thinks anything that's
not work is bad that's true that's true
that is true unfortunately
so uh
and my barber anyway i went to my barber
and
i still had gel in my hair
worst mistake i've made in a while like
never go to the bar or be pre
washing your hair yeah um because they
just can't fade it right right they just
can't you know baby could have washed
your hair you know
since i've left la the one thing that i
could get here
was a was a just the finest face
cut
my boy gabriel
from the proper in downing california
man
dude sponsored by sponsors
yeah downey he
was amazing but anyways so i can't put
my hood up because i got
well you get it do you get it all the
way down or you keep it a little long on
the top right yeah
and then see but but the thing is it
just wasn't
i'll be back hector don't worry i'm not
leaving you you know when i when i was a
kid and i moved to the bronx
i didn't know what a shape up was i went
to like a new york barber shop for the
first time
and here's me like this white kid with
like bieber hair
and all these like my kids are like yo
dude get a shape up and i walked up to
the barber like i'll take one shape up
and i walked home and i looked like a
skinhead
my mom was horrified
and
that was the last time i got a
yes most white guys can't really pull
off a buzz cut yeah
it's yeah you just look angry yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i've done it a few times buzzed my
hair quite a bit actually but yeah
i prefer i prefer a cut i feel like you
pull it off you pull off a lot of
different hairstyles
i have no mustache you don't have your
muscles i said anything yeah because you
didn't have it last time
didn't i did you no he came here and
unstashed
you warmed us up to the no stash life i
don't know yeah yeah i don't know what
made you decide to
finally give it the uh the old axe you
know it's it's actually a lot easier to
deal with this way because i don't have
to shave it
i can just take the clippers and then
just oh yeah and then
you're good to go true so that's true i
don't know is this episode sponsored by
manscaped by the way
yeah
we're going right into the brain
i guess we are now how quickly does that
guy grow in
this i just cut this on sunday but it
was like a no guard
no but i mean like how how like from
when is it gonna get back which is for
people who are listening
you know like a little stubble
how long does that take to get you to
like tom selleck
uh
to tom selleck level yeah yeah
like three months three months two to
three months yeah probably because i
just feel like i see you with the
mustache so much i feel like it comes in
yeah like in a week maybe it comes in
faster i don't know i don't keep track
hey you know what my hair does grow fast
that's all i know i i this this might be
interesting um since we all are like
folks that are on camera now a decent
amount do you guys now notice uh things
that you do that you didn't notice
before because i certainly do it and and
that main thing is the mustache
just like messing with with this part of
my sam do that i do it like way too much
i see it in like every video i'm like i
need to stop this but i just can't i
just
my it's like muscle memory to like mess
with my beard i've gone through phases
like that where there's been little
ticks that i've noticed i've do i'm sure
no one else noticed oh definitely not no
it's your own personal journey yeah do
you like correct them or yes yeah yeah
one of them was saying like oh okay yeah
we all do that sure it's a real problem
mm-hmm it's a real problem it's just a
filler word that helps you like buy some
time well yeah i think you need to raise
awareness on the use of the word like
too often can someone count the amount
of times that we said like in a
uh podcast
i'll give you guys a good one if you if
you want to replace that and sound like
super smart you say sort of oh
you know instead of like
say
this is sort of
a
sort of
it's almost english it does sound better
it's sort of but it sounds sort of
better sort of yeah
though if you said sort of all the time
yeah
like do you know what you want i don't
know
[Laughter]
[Music]
i would play with my hair a lot you play
with your nose and i'm like okay yeah
maybe that's why i wore this today you
don't do it as much now because of that
no
if it's down i it just keeps going like
this oh okay yeah i think it's like how
you guys go with this messing with him
yeah yeah the longer it gets the more i
mess with it too so it's very like
i gotta
figure out how to i mean it's no one's
bothered by it except me except me
all right so there's a couple of things
that we got to talk about in this
podcast based on the last podcast and
one of them is is
dean this question is for you oh boy um
how much do you like superhero movies
oh like
well so i am like a massive
dc comics fan like i nick called it yeah
yeah i like could tell you
like the name of every robin there's
been like
five or six robins yeah i could tell you
the entire like backstory like i know
way too much about it like i i look back
on my childhood and i like i wish i
could have slotted in
like guitar or piano instead of like i
know every like aspect of the dc
universe
so
i know yeah i know like way too much
about superhero movies okay okay now
knowing that
well so we we had some conversations
about the multiverse
yeah yeah do you feel like it ruins
superheroes
like you know storytelling in general
superhero comics have been around for 75
years and
one of the
you know at least in dc comics there was
sort of a first wave of superheroes
which was like
you know superman batman the first green
lantern the first flash
and then
as kim you know the war came around and
comics kind of dipped off a little bit
and then they came back in like the 50s
or 60s yeah and they were new versions
of these characters so like you had a
new flash a new green lantern
and one of the earliest
uh
flash story lines from this period was
flash
like runs through
because you know the flash can run super
fast but that also gives the ability to
like vibrate through realities and
through time
and he
meets the the earlier version of the
flash okay and this is like a story from
i want to say it's like from the 50s or
60s so
and from there
first in dc and then also in marvel
they
basically developed a way to
change the continuity of these
storylines that are running for you know
again 70 plus years
um they figured out a way to change the
continuity
while still
it making sense in the story universe
and
so it's a deep part of the comic book
lore and i think so you don't feel it's
an extreme departure from where we've
been no it's like
at this point multiverse is like so core
to the comic books now like
both dc and marvel like every five years
they completely reboot everything and
they have to create a story line to make
that make sense so they're like oh
freaking super boy prime punched reality
and now uh you know like it's some
stupid thing like the anti-monitor is
gonna freaking right
diddle everything
and uh
so those damn anti-monitors yeah and
there's uh
so yeah both of these companies have
realized now
i think
you know rightly so these movies
are purely nostalgia like these movies
are purely for people to be like that's
a thing from my childhood that makes me
feel good right you know and they
can just do that now
to infinity because they you know that
now they can dig back into michael
keaton you know michael keaton's gonna
be in the new
flash movie as his version of batman and
like um
and obviously marvel's like digging in
deep with the michael keaton batman from
the 90s
from 89 yeah yeah
yeah no he's gonna be
that character from that movie
with the flash from like the you know
the newest justice league movie so it's
like
it's uh
you know in a similar storyline where
flash accidentally he's like trying to
change the timeline and he accidentally
messes it up and yeah so
yeah i think it's like a core part of
uh comics and it you know obviously from
a business perspective it makes sense
for those companies you know well let me
ask you this because i asked it on the
last cast as well um and didn't really
dive too deep into it but let me see
what you think about this uh is
originality lost when you like rehash
all these characters and
like i think with the movies there's
certainly a chance for that to
happen
because
whereas
in comic books you have a new storyline
every week
right and so that goes on for years and
years so you have like hundreds of
stories and then you do like the
multiverse story where
you meet this old version of the
character or something
it feels like with the movies
they
they almost haven't really earned a lot
of that stuff yet which is the only my
only
like hesitation with it is it feels like
they haven't really sort of like earned
the right to jump back in time because
it's like
andrew garfield was spider-man like not
that long ago you know yeah like so i
don't really yeah you know
too fast yeah it's a little
again like uh and i i've always felt
this way about superhero movies in
hollywood is like
they made
uh you guys have seen watchmen
with uh you know zack snyder's watchman
they made that movie in 2009 which is
like you know watchmen as a story is
like a complete deconstruction of the
superhero genre yeah and
they made it like before the avengers
came out so it's like the superhero
genre wasn't even a thing
as much you know as
it is today and they made the storyline
that deconstructs all superhero movies
it's the same thing
marvel did the civil war arc in the
movies which is like
you need to sit like this marvel
universe has to be around for a while
before you have like them all have the
internal conflict and it felt like i
feel like we're only like two avengers
into this i think that's just because
they turned movies into shows though
yeah no and i but i i think that's why
people respond so strongly to the marvel
movies is because
like
they get so invested in the characters
and their continuing storylines and if
you notice there's no there's no solo
movies anymore like every solo movie in
quotations is
here's uh you know captain marvel's in
the background or like sam jackson they
throw him in there like they throw sam
jackson in every one just put him in
yeah he's gonna make the movie better so
they're never gonna you know they'll
never make a like
well things
there's actually some interesting drama
with spider-man they might actually
like
sony sony might be ripping and ripping
uh
uh tom hall and spider-man out of the
marvel universe because obviously they
own the character in our licensing
amount to
uh marvel studios to be in the marvel
cinematic universe but
there are theories that this new movie
is actually a way
to
reset
tom holland's
like character in
a
just spider-man universe to give him no
way home to give him no like literally
he has no way home roll credit so
i
because there's just you know there's
some like drama you know sony kind of
wants the character back to you know
they did the venom movies and the venom
movies have been pretty successful and
when sony has nothing else now that's it
they got spider-man and they
i honestly i hope
that they get spider-man back for a
little bit just so they can completely
waste him again so that they'll have to
give him back tomorrow
because like
they they've been so they've been on
their own trying to build out this like
spider-man universe yeah just like
spider-man characters universe and uh
the big new movie they got coming out is
morbius with jared leto mm-hmm you love
morbius right yeah
morbius
oh the vampire game okay
yeah it looks it was supposed to come
out last year it was one of those like
coveted movies that got pushed
it looks awful and it's like but they
like every trailer has like like this
morbius characters walking around
there's like a poster of spider-man in
the back yeah and it's like
really no relation to spider-man at all
just like they're just like hey you know
like it's spider-man universe spider-man
right and they were gonna yeah they
so this that's that's a perfect segue to
what nick was talking about because he
was talking about in in matt just kind
of saying the same thing like the the
originality of it it's it's one thing if
you have access to
comic lines that have been around for 70
years or plus
but it's another thing if you're just
trying to
and and dc caught a lot of crap for this
too though albeit it was more justified
but to just
it's it's like they're just aping it
yeah you know so you're saying that dc
movies are aping the marvel movies yeah
but then but then sony with with
spider-man is even
why are you trying to do what they're
doing why don't you just do something
else with
the with your characters well i think
the whole
cinematic universe
thing it's it's more of what you're
saying it's like we need to build this
into a
running tv show yeah you know where
every movie is like another it's a movie
but it's like in this sort of like
series and um
because yeah it's just
it's like no longer can things just be
based on an existing ip it has to be
like in the same
like
canon it has to be tied cannon is such a
weird like isn't that such a weird idea
that it's like yeah
it's made up but all of these are like
in the same universe of made up right
you know like
star wars fans get like super hardcore
about this like about delineating
between like right you know well now
they call it like legends and like the
actual like canon universe
and they're like well that didn't
actually happen it's like well none of
it actually happened
but yeah
hey guys you might notice that it's jake
here brandi o'daniel without my mustache
and beard now how did this happen well i
trimmed myself up i cleaned myself up
and i got ready for the new year
courtesy of today's sponsor manscaped
let me tell you about the best body
grooming products on the market they got
everything you might need just in time
for the new year first and foremost they
have the ultra premium body wash now
this body wash is infused with aloe vera
and sea salt to keep your skin feeling
clean nice and moisturized they also
have the lawnmower 4.0 this is the
fourth generation signature trimmer from
manscape it's got all sorts of bells and
whistles on it it's got a cutting-edge
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their advanced skin
safe technology oh and guess what it's
waterproof it's the one company that's
making a great product designed
specifically for body and groin trimming
don't go to the freaking pharmacy and
get one of those janky ones for 30
dollars
just go to manscaped get the thing that
you actually need it'll last you for a
long time it's worth the money trust me
you'll be better off for it and the 2022
you will be better off for it if you
guys are interested head on over to
manscape.com use the code cord or cast
to get 20 off plus free shipping it's a
great deal so huge thanks to them for
sponsoring they've always been great and
now back to the podcast i don't know
it's uh it's a
weird kind of thing it's all it's like
tv streaming movies it's all becoming
one thing yeah and i think we're seeing
that with disney plus you know
it's like um
with
all the star wars shows and all the
marvel shows
they're just
making and i think honestly like disney
plus is a much better platform for comic
book story lines because comic books are
inherently
serialized soap operas right yeah yeah
the stuff that they've been putting out
is very good um and i this is where it's
like me and nick kind of uh deviated in
our opinions and i i don't necessarily
agree with because i think you can tell
original stories uh through
through a universe um of characters that
you are familiar with like the loki show
is super unique to me oh it's great it's
great i love that show so much and it um
really tried new things um and was a
little bit risky with it because it it
subverted your expectations of what you
thought a loki show was going to be
um oh [ __ ] now they're in like this
other world that we've never seen before
or you know there's these time cops
that's crazy that's so cool
stylistically it's very difficult
super unique yeah and
yeah and i think there's a lot more room
to do that on disney plus because
there's more time and this like the
season to flesh out the characters and
um
and again we've seen it with like the
mandalorian is
like a very different approach to what
they're doing in the movies yeah and
more what people are looking for like
more of what the like hardcore star wars
fans are looking for and they they have
like they can just quarter off a section
and do just that you know it doesn't
have to be
because if it's if it's a movie that
comes out in theaters it has to hit
every it has to check everything gotta
do everything yeah yeah gotta get
everyone but you gotta but yeah but even
with the big movies the big marvel
movies um guardians of the galaxy i
thought the first one was like it was
also trying something pretty unique uh
that we hadn't really seen before and we
weren't really familiar with those
characters either so it was you know
kind of a departure from from what we
knew and what was safe and it's funny
because i'm making fun of sony for like
picking out these like obscure
stories that nobody cares about but
marvel has done
and
like dc to an extent with uh suicide
squad but like
picking out these like kind of off
kilter sort of like sea tier stories
like guardians of the galaxy is like
nobody cared about guardians the galaxy
in the comic books yeah uh like choosing
that kind of stuff and
just giving it to a filmmaker and being
like hey here's like something that
nobody cares about so you can do
whatever you want with it yeah and um
that's where i think the originality
will come in with these
stories is if it's like
you know
kind of
it doesn't have so much
expectations and hype on it like
this new spider-man movie it has to hit
certain things you know like it's oh
yeah toby maguire has to show up do you
think it's gonna say with great power
comes great responsibility do you think
it's gonna do any of that what do you
mean like it's gonna hit any of those
things that they think
oh so
yeah yeah it's gonna freaking yeah it's
gonna
like venom's gonna be in it it's gonna
it's literally gonna have
everything you think will be in it i
feel like it's they're gonna have to do
because at this point
at this point if somebody says something
they can like
just go
like pull it up on the volume an unreal
engine
like call hey tom you want to come in
for like five seconds and like shoot
this new scene where we got freaking i
don't know
booster gold in there or something i
don't know so none of this kills it for
you none of this like machining no it's
like refined machining like a cnc cutter
just cutting out stories into like
perfect blocks
my like my thing is always like there's
so many other stories happening right
now whether it's on streaming or whether
like these movies
sorry guys they're for me
people who were super into the these old
movies and they're just gonna keep
rolling it out and it's you know that's
the stuff that makes that makes money in
theaters and it's but yeah i think
to say that like
that's the death of originality it's
like
yeah i think we
like
theaters only matter
like theaters are just theme park rides
now they're not like
they're not for like the death of
originality died in theaters a long time
ago yeah absolutely yeah and like in
like tent pole hollywood filmmaking
that's you know that's out the door
right but
there's you know plenty of awesome stuff
that's being made on a smaller scale and
i think right it's so much more
democratic separate that's separate from
from theater yeah yeah we were talking
about that in the last one too and it's
just like that
they can't take any risk like it's just
it's just if you're going to do that
theater model with the nationwide
distribution and the two weeks of
advertisement and
everything like it's yeah it's just it's
gotta be that because that's the only
thing that still makes that whole
and it gets lumbering machine function
you know and as it gets more expensive
like it gets proven constantly that like
you try something original
and it's
not gonna make right the money that an
avengers movie is going to make and you
know you could say hey
studio why don't you take more of a risk
yeah but they're like
you know we're spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on these
movies we can't lose money on them no
yeah that's what that that that's what
i'm saying as well is it's that they
make three bad ones like the studio's
gone yeah it's like nope you're done
even yeah even the superhero movies
aren't a safe bet right they've lost
tons of money on those movies so
yeah it's just the theater model is
it just
i don't know with so much with so many
entertainments so much power comes so
much responsibility yeah exactly
that's what we want to hear jake thank
you
you're welcome
[Music]
yeah i thought it'd be interesting to
hear your take on that um any other hot
takes um i don't know you knew so much
about oh yeah it's like yeah that like
that in star wars i like it's definitely
people
i just come out swinging with these
people
yeah i was like this the whole time
but hot takes on like hollywood no on
on the superhero genre whether it's like
uh
something that
a maybe an underserved character or a uh
dude give a freaking martian man hunter
out here man martian man hunter
i think i know what that is son they
snuck him into the justice league movie
yeah he needs his own movie
they need to get another green lantern
movie going that one with ryan reynolds
was
absolute butt trash
is that the one set that brogan was in
no oh that was green hornet yeah you
know funny
taika waititi is plays the best friend
the director of all the new thor movies
okay like plays his best buddy in that
movie in the
um green lantern green lantern oh wow
all right um i got a few other questions
uh
yeah for for all three of you actually
we were talking about um
lifestyle creep
previously to this
and uh it was in relation to nicholas
cage and how he was able to
how he was able to go bankrupt basically
after
you know everything he's done he
speaking of comics he bought the first
issue of action comics oh superman
that's probably the first million
dollars oh my god what the first issue
of superman for a million dollars yeah
well there you go now we know i mean
somebody's got necklaces i guess he's
spending his money on
um
do you think you guys are relatively new
to the you know the corridor crew and
the history of corridor being adults
have you seen
any
quote unquote lifestyle creep happen in
the studio
as of recent
like things that weren't around when you
came in that are now around now and to
be expected yeah and are now expected
yeah look i've already expressed my
thoughts on corn dogs so we can move
past that
um
no i i
we have two microwaves it's nice to feel
like we have you know
amenities and it's comfy because like
even when i first started it was still
like we were all sitting out here on our
desks a little janky yeah yeah i was
kind of sick we have ac dean you and i
definitely when did you start what year
2018 we had beginning of 20
like very beginning 2019 20. okay yeah
we had a we had that one okay we had
just one though yeah there was nothing
back here yeah we didn't get this until
the end of
i 2019 know this was a steam room
it was an absolute steam used to be the
bath yeah you had guests in here we had
guests in here in fact if you're if
you're a fan of this podcast go watch
the logan paul episode that nico did
with him and you can tell how just hot
oh my god
it's just freaking steaming in there oh
now we wear robes in here
now we have to wear robes actually this
is like producing its own climate and
i'm about to take it off
this is my own steam room in here yeah i
know
i know yeah you guys know i'm always
cold so we brought the steam room to our
personal i'm getting kind of hot too i'm
gonna take this sweatshirt off yeah i
would say
i do
miss a little bit of the the scrappy
sort of yeah like early days
or at least early days of me being here
yeah because
yeah no it's it's definitely more comfy
more like yeah it feels like
you know
i don't know what scrappiness do you
miss
yeah let's get into this i want to know
the details let me know because i don't
see the
is not losing
scrappiness but also being like not but
also being professional
yes and but i think there it's an
inherent balance
and an inherent like
trade-off right to get certain things i
almost feel like they're the antithesis
of one another yeah we lose the uh the
bull pen feel right if you if you know
what i mean right i do
you know i'm just like everybody's right
here so it's like if something happens
we all share that moment immediately you
know like somebody farts
you know
somebody jumps over a table and breaks
their shoulder blade yeah yeah
everyone's there to witness it but also
at the same time that does distract from
work exactly exactly my god did that
happen a lot when we were working down
here yeah um
yeah i mean it was getting really hard
to get anything done yeah because
something is all was always filming yeah
and you're at your desk like screaming
right behind you yeah like
like literally screaming
wren specifically is screaming behind
you yeah yeah yeah right behind you
you're right behind you yeah right
behind you and um
like every act episodes we would all be
working behind
the first
30 or 40 episodes it's just griffin in
the background no i'm like the first
couple episodes i am in the back like
just oh yeah just freaking yeah because
i was i was on that that wall
when i first got here i think yeah the
like the jank desk before i got my own
desk yeah i was like that was my hazing
i bought that desk for ten dollars at
the thrift store across the street oh
wait and then when i when i got here i
used that desk yeah you got the yes you
got the haze desk the brown one on the
wheels brown one on the wheels
nick had that one too before you and
carl michael had it before him
a lineage of the shitty desk see now
these new cats come in man they get
their big desks they got their rtx
that's what i mean that's what i'm
worried about
i don't want to worry about it legit
have concerns about that but i think
we get romantic about it because
honestly i'll like i'll say this i like
when i first started having had watched
the videos back in the day i had
romanticized late nights yeah in my mind
right because i was like
like like we're all gonna be working
like yeah you know we're all part of
this thing and yeah as soon as i started
doing that consistently i was like i am
so tired
i don't want to do this anymore yeah and
um
yeah i i one time i slept back here when
it was in the steam room era and the
steam room and um
it was more of that vibe when we were
all down here yeah and um
it it is nice
there's more balance i spent a week down
you can
god
and breathe wasn't that long never
leaving
uh well leaving to go out into the floor
to work
were you
like did you when you renovated the
studio upstairs
there was a i i had i had a
bed up there yeah yeah but then i set it
up and then i was waiting for the
renovations to start
and and nico had already moved out so i
was living up there when i wasn't
working yeah and then
he moved out and then we started
renovations and then i showed up
to stay here for the week and
i went upstairs to studio three and it
was completely gutted and i went into
the bathroom by the
main floor and the shower was ripped out
and i turned on the light and there's
like roaches on the floor oh you know
because they live in the walls yeah yeah
they do and uh so they were just out
and and then i went into the back room
and it's just like sheetrock torn out
and there's sheetrock dust on everything
and and there was and none of the
electricity worked
and and and i go well i guess i'm
sleeping in the podcast room
[Laughter]
there's another thing
this has like for some reason as we've
grown there's been less cockroaches i
don't know what that has to do with this
is less oh it's we sealed upstairs oh
okay yeah that's what that spray foam is
with all the faces on it there's another
thing you could romanticize is like i'm
i i miss chasing around cockroaches
do you think like
if
you know
so that there's this new kid upstairs
right and he's like you know we're
prospecting him it's like see what you
got kid it's like
if he doesn't go through that do you
think he's gonna like oh yes i i don't
think do you think he's gonna have the
same soul i think
what
is great about this environment is that
a lot of the people who have come in
were fans you know or were people who
loved the content so
you know
for
for
us
you know it it was definitely coming in
regardless of what the environment was i
was like i'm i'm all in because i you
know just growing up watching this stuff
so
it yeah i don't
it's definitely like
yeah it gives you like a little bit of
more
i don't know toughness with i actually i
don't know i think it does i mean
jordan
you
the costume room
passage i had no idea what was going on
i was like i was like i can't do this
forever
but it but just it just keeps getting a
mess i guess i am going to do this
i mean yeah i guess everyone has their
own things they're right of passage when
you come here but then again like new
rite of passages will occur like the
more we grow the more like there's gonna
be different things to be done yeah so
every time someone new comes
they're going to be doing something that
no one else has ever even done because
now there's like the low man workout
yeah there's always something new
did you have when you first got here did
you have to do the
metadata for the videos
no
i did
i did i did too i don't know how many
times i probably just fell asleep i
thought i was gonna be editing videos
and i was sitting here like putting in i
didn't even know what metadata was
before i started working here oh and i'm
learning it over discord too yeah i
didn't even meet half of you guys before
and i'm on discord like
hi
i did some of the node metadata yeah
that was that was about it oh cause you
were like
node i i
did node for a bit yeah yeah for
strictly jordan started she had to go
through every
video
yeah we've ever made
so she christian yep so she made it
through the whole because i did like i
did some
but i definitely didn't do it jordan
went through everything i think at this
point i've been through video that's
respect
yeah whether it's
thumbnails are going from youtube to the
website
metadata yeah so for people who don't
know that's like
like
it's literally like
the description like fixing the
description of every old video there's
no
automated process for this still yeah to
this day
it's just you you go you scroll through
your uploaded videos you you sort by
oldest right you started the old just
started and you just and you bring in
like because you know we have the stuff
that we put in the description so you
add like the new formatting copy paste
you put in what was this video about oh
this was you know sam and nico were
having a good time and then you go to
the next one
arrow check out our new merch for weeks
it took you weeks
so it's it's like uh we have uh
she's cashback palpate she's just
thinking about ptsd from that
so yeah that's
the back breaking labor that we do here
[Music]
so yeah if those were if those were the
days were
you know right we were getting humbled
by hitting control v and
who are iron ore miners heard me talking
that way about labor they would i don't
know what they would do
wouldn't be good roll over in their
grave yeah
that's why i don't talk about it like
that
yeah okay so well i'll say this though
i'll say i think there's still a level
of like scrappiness and you know um love
of filmmaking that you um put into
really hard work um because yeah it of
course it's still there when you're
really passionate about a project here
it's like you know for example the doing
late nights on the spiderman rated r
video was something that i really wanted
to do because i wanted it to be as good
as possible yeah so those late nights
felt really like fun and invigorating in
a way that isn't like a day-to-day thing
but when it happens it's like [ __ ] yeah
i'll stay until two three in the morning
to get this done because it's it's
something that i believe in you know
yeah and that's i think that's always
going to be present with any of this
content that we make if it's something
that we believe in yeah yeah and i i
think a certain amount of that is
healthy like a it's it's the sugar in
the food pyramid you know like you gotta
have a little bit of that because that
i don't know i've been there so many
times as well like i
yeah yeah yeah you have to you have to
like
care about your work enough to do that
every once in a while right now
even if we are starting to become more
of a
you know company rather than just like a
group of like filmmakers it's like it
still is a group of filmmakers like
inherently and i don't think that
is going anywhere so as long as we have
that i think like
everybody's still gonna be like sam and
i's phrase for the company culture the
company culture at corridor digital used
to be [ __ ] the man
we are the man now well that's my
concern man i don't i don't i don't know
i don't want to become that well you
gotta have the structure still yeah but
it seems like you guys find a good
balance with it i hope so
every production needs structure yeah
damn right how does it function
yeah
how does it function it's great
it comes great responsibility yes
how many more times can we say it
probably a few more a few more at least
we'll get together it'll never be as
good as when all right so
put that in the metadata so back to the
back to the lifestyle crepe thing
are you talking about our lifestyles or
the lifestyle of the studio studio
lifestyle
well and our own lifestyle i would say
big thing for me and jordan knows this
snacks
that's where i'm going into my life
that's where i'm going with this my life
is not happy about snacks
i have no
the looks the looks he gives me while
he's elbow deep and sour patch kids
like it's your fault it's not pretty
yeah i have like i have zero willpower
when it comes to sugar and like
i lit like i will get mad at my
girlfriend if she brings home like sugar
sweets like because her mom like will
give her like all these mexican candies
when she comes on and then she'll come
home with them and i'll be like
throw those out like i
said i will eat them all tonight
you know
i saw you snagging on some starburst
earlier every time every time i walk
through the kitchen he's there it's like
so now it's like it used to be we you
know we had a water cooler when i
started here like i get my water and i
go back to my desk now i get my water
and there's a cornucopia
of sweets and treats and i like
it's just there for the taking and like
somebody's got to do it yeah i'd like
somebody gotta eat them snacks yeah like
i you might have this mentality too jake
like my grand like my grandma if i
didn't eat my whole meal right she'd be
like right what's wrong sit down and eat
the whole meal yeah and
if i see free food i'm gonna eat all of
the food
so it's just there may not be any free
snacks again yeah gotta eat them all now
that's the mentality i'm like there's
free candy here now that's a wolf's
mentality yeah well you know it's it's i
gotta scarf all this now yes
going to sit in my belly
and yeah i just i have zero willpower
luckily luckily i'm still a young lad
and i have metabolism but that's quickly
going away
so
i get healthy options
i do there's
there's trail mix yeah there's beef
jerky but there's still there's still
other options
there's a thing
much less tastier there's a thing uh
steve jobs you know he wore the same
thing every day
and the idea was because he was a
psychopath or because he was
maybe a little bit but it was because
there's an idea that was a joke
willpower is not something that you just
brute force it's actually if you
set up your life in such a way that you
don't have to make certain decisions
you have more willpower think of it like
you have a willpower bar right right and
so like
if you like if you want to work out in
the morning and you lay out your your uh
workout clothes the night before you're
gonna be more likely to go work out
uh if i
at the grocery store don't buy sweets
i'm not gonna eat them when i'm home
that's wise that's true that's very wise
we have them in the studio and i have
zero willpower yeah i'm never gonna stop
that's a good thought though i like that
i'm gonna think about that a little bit
more because it's it's true like if you
set your life up in such a way
then
the things that are hard for you
become less hard yeah this is something
daniel and i share we both wear the same
thing every day and it's like uh that's
why i brought up steve jobs because
steve jobs wore the same thing every day
and that was the ideas is you uh option
paralysis i believe is the phrase
so you don't have option paralysis you
know you go to the grocery store and
there's
uh 40 brands of cereals you're gonna
stand there forever if there were just
three options you would just grab one
and go you know
[Music]
interesting
we literally have like eight options
up in the kitchen when did can i ask a
serious question jordan when did the
corn dogs how did that come into the
picture we really just want to pick
apart the corn dog i want to know about
this because that wasn't how did that
happen it's because i was going to
ralph's this whole time yeah i ended up
going to smart and final one day yeah i
ended up realizing how much cheaper
smart and final was i was like 50 60
under budget and that's like the dollar
store of grocery stores but and i'm
getting like the same stuff so then i
went back the next time and i was like
in my head i was like i have more room
here i said what would these
men want to eat
burritos corn dogs something that you
can just into the microwave into the
oven right
no it was it was there was just in the
freezer looking at me so ren didn't ask
you to get corn dogs no he was very
excited he was excited about it he had i
believe he had three in like 30 minutes
yeah i kept seeing him go back for more
yeah he was very he wasn't
the the one wasn't enough and then last
friday griffin took a corndog heated
that up took a burrito
no he did not it was never on camera he
did it it wasn't on camera
that's so gross he just did it on his
own
and i caught him and he was he's a
savage
i don't i feel like i don't know anymore
and i mean part of it is all my fault i
am literally buying
the concoctions that he's making you're
putting him yeah you're putting an
environment around him
of uh
horrible no rational person would think
that you put a corn dog inside of a
burrito
how do you do it you gotta
he opened up the burrito you got to open
it up put the corn dog in it wrap it
around pull the stick out pull the stick
there's so many layers just use the
stick to force the corn dog into the
stick right
right maybe it's ingenious i mean this
is coming from a man who has a dish that
he is self-termed a griff pile a grip
file
smell like i smell it dude when he walks
in with it yeah and griffin soggy cup as
well
is that a real thing i like it
for the video
oh
[Laughter]
it's like a bowl of cereal but with like
the condiments of a nacho yeah you know
so it's like
like the the salsas the milk
the chips are the cereal
you know the cheese is like the
marshmallows
yeah the jalapenos are the marshmallows
these are my concerns it's the cheese
and salsas yeah no we're degenerating
we're degenerating
ten pounds heavier two steps forward one
step back here yeah yeah in a way we get
more work done because you don't have to
leave to go get food
that is yeah that is helpful because i i
used to have to walk down to the end of
the street to get a burrito yeah now i
just grab one of those frozen meals
i pop it in the microwave
we have an air fryer for god's sake
oh there is an air fryer yeah now we're
getting a little too fancy yeah that's
what i'm saying where is the line yeah
that's what i'm saying
where is the lion who knows how i'll be
installing the phone i used to fry his
own air
is the personal chef the line is that is
that too far personal
no i wa i've walked in so you want it
no i'll do it
like i walked in this morning and there
were on the
we have a griddle now
there were pieces of bacon sizzling
but we do have a breakfast club if you'd
like to join me we're going to take this
we're going to i remember
i used to have the sizzling bacon was
amazing
the
aroma what's wrong with that that's
fresh food right there i don't know
frozen
bs no i remember i used to have to walk
over to clint's desk and beg him for a
piece of his protein cookie
i just have to wait and tell you
freaking mario showed up with the taco
truck just to get lunch
every day
you actually so we've destroyed a
business
they're still around they don't come
down this street anymore though because
they know
they can smell pile yeah smell the bacon
coming up they are across from big bear
though in the mornings that's true yeah
and in the evenings i think yeah every
time i get here on monday morning and i
go to big bear
get my coffee yeah they're they're right
there here's my pitch
lose all the snacks
get a little little little catering from
from them see that's so inconvenient
though
we want the snacks the snacks have
longevity you know i like getting up
from my desk grabbing a goldfish every
once in a while
going back yeah you know the only time
we used the only time we used to have
goldfish around here was after a
production
and then nika would steal half the box
and he'd put it on his desk yeah
and like take ownership yeah and then
he'd take ownership of it but that's
also why i've realized who likes what
and i get that specific stuff in the
kitchen
i know what sam likes right
blueberry pop-tarts one at a time he
leaves half the bag open every time he
does every time yes it's such a nico
thing
sam opens the pop-tart box and goes what
animal has done this dude i just want
one what else have you noticed jordan
what do you like he can't eat dairy so i
have to get snacks i don't have dairy
and is that where the almond malt came
from
i mean almond milk is just honestly a
bunch of us blank for almond milk milk
is better
i don't think it's good to drink milk
milk is great what's wrong with you
drinking it for you
i i i switch it up we get we get the
almond milk at home we get the yeah but
i i've actually started getting back
into whole milk really
you you drink it after and this is the
thing my mom's a vegan and she she
there's like a plant-based burger place
that opened near us and she visited and
she tried it she's like these burgers
are so good i took a bite and i was like
this is the worst thing i've ever tasted
and it's the same thing with like plant
milk so you drink it for a while and
you're like this is great and then you
drink milk and you're like this is so
much better i can't really stand the
taste of milk anymore if my latte is
actually made with milk agreed i'm like
i can't do it right away it's so
interesting it's like including
i we go through well i have three kids
and we're just we're just going through
milk all the time yeah it's no stopping
it no stopping and it's just gallon
after gallon after gallon
it has a little mucus it doesn't doesn't
actually when they have the sniffles we
don't give it to them because it makes
it worse but there's certain kinds of uh
milk that are better for your allergies
but that's actually very controversial
because you can also get a bunch of
diseases like raw milk yeah so that's
the game pasteurized it's like you can
and maybe this is a great metaphor for
the studios like
you could
you know drink raw milk right and you
could
well you usually really bolster your
immune system
but you could also get like some kind of
rare parasitic disease yeah that's like
or you could drink skim milk right this
is you know we're moving towards skim
milk right and you know you're safe you
don't get any allergies right but are
you really living
that's what i'm saying that's why you go
for the vitamin d whole milk yeah that's
the good middle ground i think we're
right i need to have milk
too no i don't need milk you have the
only reason
i'm asking for milk this is a metaphor
no this is just i the whole reason why i
wanted to do this podcast is just so i
could ask jordan without asking her to
get milk
no
no i don't need the the only reason i
drink milk now is because i have it with
oreos is gonna like and we give it to
our kids yeah and then i'll have a glass
of it like when i have an oreo
but
we don't need it we don't need oreos no
no more but the half and half is a real
thing
the half and half is a real thing on the
coffee he said that the the vanilla
creamer and all that ruins the coffee it
does
there's no doubt about it
i wouldn't know
oh yeah i got a tea tea oh you're a tea
guy but if you have a matcha latte like
a tea like uh
gentleman
a gentleman
because you're from the east coast
no i um
this is gonna sound so pretentious but i
went to
[Laughter]
and
japan
i tried matcha there and i was like i'm
really into this oh okay yeah that's how
you break down so good yeah honestly
that's a t-boy i'm a t-boy i love i love
the tea that he brings yeah i gotta get
i gotta get a pack of whatever the stuff
that you bought you were drinking like
one ounce at a time though and it was
really good
he would come back to his desk like this
yeah and then he would leave in 10
minutes and go boil more refined
just you would have been pulling out
every single tannin every single why was
the cup so sweet that's not even
enjoyable
you guys you buy your freaking
mcdonald's coffee yeah i don't buy you
guys
that's nico i drink black rifle coffee
yeah black rifle coffee
very good it's a good cop good good
coffee is good but it's just tastes like
coffee like teas you have so many you
have different variations but you do
have different variations of coffee and
where it's grown how it's roasted
but it is how you decide to make it but
that matters a lot
doesn't matter there's like five or six
different categories of tea and they all
taste completely different
i was roasting my own country for a
while i should get back into that
that's pretty cool yeah it's kind of
funny did you have the like the thing
that you sort of it's automated it's
like an oven it's like a little um
it's like a
panini oven okay but it's it's for
coffee it's got a little roller inside
of it and it
keeps it going and then your whole house
smells like rope like fresh coffee
when you buy like roasted kind of smell
it's um it smells so good when you buy
roasted beans in a bag
how like how long ago were they roasted
do you like usually uh i i don't know um
but it's not that long oh it's it's
usually you know less than
a week or two oh okay um at least you
know from brcc i don't know about like
folgers yeah or whatever but freaking
dominoes because you're in there
dunking donuts domino's coffee and it's
just acidic well brcc only has two
roasters they have one in salt lake and
they have one in tennessee so they have
like a whole facility where they roast
it oh yeah oh that's crazy oh they have
yeah and and then those roasters you
have to like custom make them
um i saw one of them doing it in a pan
in the field oh yeah you can do that
that's like the freaking most hardcore
winner yeah it's actually not that hard
it's not like hardcore like just
freaking out yeah yeah it's badass
you throw it on the fire and it's hell
yeah you wait until it starts to do with
that second crack oh it's got two cracks
coffee has two cracks when it roasts the
first one usually after about 10 10 or
15 minutes at the right 10 minutes at
the right temperature and then it'll
start popping
and then uh and then
they'll kind of be a it'll stop and then
they'll be like a minute or two where
you don't hear much and then it'll start
popping again that's the second pop and
so right in the middle
into that second pop is where you get
flavor and then after
you know you get most of the beans into
the second pop
then it just becomes like burnt coffee
which is great which is
yeah that's what they call it that's
what dark roast is but dark roast the
reason why like starbucks even their
medium pikes plate or even their medium
roasts are dark still because it's it's
way easier to control yeah you don't
have to be precise
yeah you can't get medium roasts that
are consistent as often at that quantity
as you can with the dark roast because
you basically just take the flavor out
of it well it's the same thing with um
with tea at least in the steeping
process it's like
you know if you like a tea bag you just
leave it in your cup of water and then
you like drink it later yeah at some
point right like
with um like more traditional like
chinese ways of making tea like you
you know it's precise temperatures you
put it in you like wait a certain amount
of time and then pour it out and you do
like different levels of steeping as the
leaves get more like
uh
you know gorge with water and um
yeah no it's it i i love getting in all
that stuff and um isn't it a myth that
the darker the roast so stronger the
coffee yes yeah everyone said they'll
want dark roast because they think it's
going to be more catholic it has nothing
to do with it it has everything to do
with the bean itself
yeah because it's not like you're just
yeah coffee's
the beans different types of beans
have different
caffeine levels yeah okay and the main
bean is the arabica bean and then
there's another one i can't remember its
name
but the arabica bean the roasted dark
roasted arabica bean is like what most
people think of when they think of
coffee
did you know the main
strain of coffee in the americas
is all
uh descended from one plant from i think
it was
louis the 14th or something
he had a yeah he had a single coffee
plant
because it basically
uh it was like very much controlled by
uh
like arab traders in the middle east and
they didn't want anybody to get these
plants because they had a monopoly on
coffee but like the king of france had
one plant and there was this dude who
hired a courtesan to like sneak in oh
and and steal the plant and then this
guy took it in a glass vessel
across
you know the atlantic ocean and
literally like had to give it like that
they had to ration water on the ship and
he had to give it some of his water to
keep it alive yeah and that single plant
i mean it's a story but like
that single plant is apparently all of
like you know colombian coffee like
everything in the americas
yeah i've heard this story yeah that's
the coffee movie just him
sneaking out of some middle-aged arabian
like castle like
did you know that i was reading uh a
book on the history of texas and
three-fifths
of all
value
of agriculture
produced
comes from
uh
like
plants
that were original agriculture of the
native americans
just in texas or in the u.s and and i i
don't i don't know if it's globally
i believe it was globally in the 20th
century like the amount of value of the
yeah
of the
agricultural goods produced it's so
funny three fifths of that came from
plants that were original native
american plants i just that they
originally cultivated for some reason i
had googled that the other day oh really
and like the list was like
you know the stuff you expect like
squash yeah um
you know but tobacco cotton corn corn
beans but also potato tomatoes
tomatoes
and potatoes yeah so tomatoes was the
one the big one i didn't know and like
so you think about it that's you know
europeans get here 1500s what were
italians eating before 1500 they didn't
have tomatoes yeah yeah that it can't
eat things they just bread all this is
freaking crazy i guess yeah bread with
some salt on it yeah yeah fruit
i wonder if they figured out pasta
before tomatoes
yeah like what would they put on it i
guess you could make some food
rosemary i guess they're yeah
interesting and then irish people you
know yeah just eating dirt i guess
dirty potatoes i'm irish
you can say that yeah you're right you
don't want to offend any irish people
they've already been offended enough
that's okay
oh man but uh yeah and we were just
talking about this with thanksgiving
it's interesting with thanksgiving you
don't really think about this a lot but
a lot of those
foods that we're eating yeah the whole
obviously the holidays the whole idea of
the meal and like what goes into it is
all like a
banquet of these indigenous indigenous
foods which is pretty cool i think yeah
and it's like i think it's worth um
i think daniel in his crew cuts video
kind of had put this succinctly but i
think it's
it's a worthy
you know if we're trying to
sort of
uh
move past certain like simplistic forms
of uh viewing history or viewing these
holidays
it's uh
you know
everything is in that holiday already to
like
pay
homage and respect to indigenous people
because like we're already eating the
foods it's just you need to like
you know think about that and respect
that and
yeah yeah that's super important i mean
it's not like it happened on its own
it's not and and
that that uh
yeah it's like that's part of this
country i understand why we're here yeah
yeah
so thank you for the history lesson that
was actually very nice
oh every once in a while
here's another fun fact random trivia
from me
i know it's unsolicited the um
apaches okay
the same word that they used
for sorry
when they referred to a man
they also referred to a warrior they
were the same word
in the apache language
that's isn't that crazy that blew my
mind yeah wow it's like you weren't you
heard me you weren't a man
you weren't a man until you were also a
warrior mm-hmm right yeah
wow yeah you'd be 30 and just
interesting a boy
it was so like it was so inherent in
their culture yeah it was so much the
same thing well
hmm it's wild yeah kind of blew my mind
it's like the opposite of where we're at
now
that's why i'm worried about the weak
times and it all comes back because
sauce
good times create soft people but we
need like we need a little bit like
coming back to the studio you need a
little bit of softness no of course it
can't be brutality yeah can it be
scalping people right
yeah we're modern people you didn't
release the video on time
no obviously and that's obviously the
counter argument um but it's not about
either it's about a balance i think yeah
in all things yeah you gotta you gotta
find the things that keep you balanced
otherwise i don't know
just i don't want to become netflix
i don't want to become
no offense to rooster teeth they're
great but that's not i don't think
that's the direction for us
you know i just
it's that small you lose that small
batch you know yeah private reserve yeah
yeah that freaking gmo free content yeah
so so i'll hold off on the hot tub
installation let's hold off on that i
mean we just got the dishwasher
a sauna we're already like pretty close
i'm i'm sweating it's not a bad idea
you're in a sauna right now dude i hit
the sauna this morning son look if you
want to do a sauna all we have to do is
to podcast down here without the ac on
yeah a steam room is easy just we get
dude we don't change anything
we don't change anything we just get one
of those coal boxes that you squeeze
water on yeah and we just steam it out
in here dude get a bunch of wood you're
just coming at lunch
you get your sauna in get a steam in you
get your shock proteins
is that too far probably i think that's
that's where the line is right then we
get an ice bath oh that's the hard
that's the hard way like yeah that's how
we get when is that i'm very familiar
with ice baths i used to yeah
no but when i was oh when you're running
yeah when i was running notre dame had
like every facility under the sun
and
yeah every time after after we ran it
was ice bath dude well i caught a cold
shower every morning son
hell yeah dude i do when i can't do a
cold i just do brutal like a little i've
been acting lukewarm
yeah nah dude you got to get that cold
shower man it does wake you up yeah dude
at night no night it'll wake you up too
much i feel like yeah
it'll like yeah jolt you up i had to do
that one time when my heat was broken in
my place and i was in pain but it makes
you just get in and get it out of that i
look forward to experience in my life
dude how long do you think the one time
i think oh freaking like two three
minutes take my time oh take your time
see that take my time because you hit do
you take your time in the water or you
just stand next to them here's what
happens you get
wash yourself and then jump it takes
five minutes to get in because you're
hyping yourself up and then you get in
and then you just go
this is what's happening and then it's
the best right because it feels warm but
i just remember that you just wash
really fast and get out no it's you you
deep breaths
you know and you just freaking accept
because it can't hurt you right you just
success no that's that's true there's a
lot of value to that just applicable to
many aspects of life but a lot of times
people freak out especially about pain
or like doctors and stuff like that and
you know i always go well
i'm not gonna die from this
it's just cold water yeah and it is good
for you it's good for your health yeah
is it it brings discipline in the
morning yeah it actually helps with like
colds and your immune system does it
they got they got freaking monks out
there rolling around the snow you know
as they do as they do they roll around
in the snow and that they're like
they're insides you take a like
thermometer they're like they're hot
they're like you can make it colder
that's true that's some big ice colder
yeah iceman hoff yeah wim hof dude
that's that's where i started in the
cold showers from wim hof really he's
just this crazy like
what is he like
danish he just runs outside in the snow
barefoot and he's like everyone come on
and everyone's like no trying yeah it's
actually a beautiful story his his he
was like super distraught after losing
his wife and he was like i have to find
he having all these existential
questions and he's just like
i just had this urge to like jump into a
cold lake
and it like just from that point it like
fixed everything brought that clarity he
does all these yoga sessions outside and
his ice it's ice
yeah he's gonna sound just like a little
bit of snow
in texas like ice yoga ice yoga
yeah well like
it's all about getting in touch with
your body you know right well maybe you
think because we have it so good that we
need to live those extremes to like oh
normal probably it's like counter
balance all this all the corn dogs with
counterbalance like if you want
you have to eat it in an ice bath yeah
like did you take a cold shower this
morning well you're not eating a corn
dog yeah
getting an ice bath son
yeah five minutes in the ice bath i do
think or no dogs you do need you need to
re you do need to respect how
efficient it is to get to get to just
get a corn dog in
i mean think about that for a second
it's very efficient all the animal the
animal has to be raised all the parts
like all the like what it takes to make
a corn dog then you gotta yeah yeah
they're massively produced slaughter it
friggin
process the grain
put it all together and then they have a
stick
sodium in there you gotta get a stick
into it
you got to bring it to market you got to
you got to advertise it and bring it to
market dogs even need advertising
anymore the stick is a step too far for
me like like bread
bread
bread was invented to hold your food
true and you need a stick to hold your
bread now yeah that's too far do you
think it's more than right when food
came before bread or do you think bread
happened and then they were like hey you
can hold stuff with the bread what do
you think came first i think it's kind
of
no bread probably came first the bread
came maybe
we were we definitely had food long
before we had bread though yeah
but were you putting like a raw
steak on a piece of bread no you just
eat it yeah
well we developed our culinary
sensibilities and
eventually that led us to uh also
including our utensils
inside of our inside like pre-made
pre-made and said right true
yeah i think this whole conversation is
just leading to the whether or not the
personal chef is the line that we've
crossed with lifestyle creep yeah what
will i buy on the next grocery run i
don't know i'm excited now guys if you
have any thoughts on what jordan should
buy on the next grocery run
let us know your faves here in the
comments and uh
you know maybe maybe we'll talk about
them in the video
maybe wren will eat three of them in
less than 20 minutes that's a guarantee
[Laughter]
all right well hey
thanks for coming on the cast everybody
um i hope that you guys are warm
and uh yeah i'm sorry i do i'm sweating
okay i feel so but i can't take it off i
had to i had no choice and uh here's to
um originality the death of originality
in the marvel universe
does it happy not to go in there we go
[Music]
um
[Music]